Hello, Internet.
Let's talk about this map, this discussion,
and on the electoral college in general.
In my video "Problems with the electoral college" of 2011,
I made a mistake by using the city limits as part of the discussion
instead of the most extensive metropolitan area.
The scholar in my interior continues to tell me that "this is a technically correct" section.
I used the municipal boundaries because metropolitan areas are often vague and absurdly large:
The metropolitan area of ​​New York is 6700+ mi² in four states
and from where I grew up, it seemed that much of this area
It had nothing to do with the city of New York.
That is why, at that time, I ignored the metropolitan borders.
But using the municipal limits strictly in that video was a mistaken decision in the retro-view.
In addition to being a bad argument to do,
above all did not address the problems that this map represents.
And that's right! Half of the population lives in counts in gray.
And in addition, the map teaches the fundamental division between the United States and other countries
which is translated partly into the policies we see:
the difference between rural and urban areas.
If the trend continues, an increasing percentage of the country will live in urban areas.
In another eight or sixteen years, this map will still be more extreme:
the metropolitan areas will be even more dense.
What if you are in favor of the electoral college,
There will be another reason to keep it.
Now is when we have to discuss the idea that the electoral college
Ensures that the president is chosen by the states.
It does not.
A candidate can win the polling school with only the eleven larger states.
This collection may seem implausible, but as urbanization and the policies that take place continue,
every time seems more plausible.
The electoral college does not assure that the president wins with many states,
not even with geographically diverse states.
Now, "Should the president represent the citizens, or should he represent the states?"
It is an unanswered question.
It treats preferences about the style of government.
One transfers the power to the federal level, while the other moves it to the states.
And given the size of the country and the difference of its geographies,
It is reasonable to think that increasing the power of states is the best
And the least divisive solution to the problem of governance.
But the electoral college does not help in that.
The last results have been geographically dispersed,
but the electoral college does not guarantee this result.
Blind everyone in California, leaving only one person in each state
and the polling station will say: "California alone decides."
We could have a system in which the president must win a majority of states,
Which is what the electoral college is in some way ... but it is not.
The choice only makes it look.
The protection of the electoral college is only an illusion.
Although I still like the electoral college,
Although it does not really protect the small states,
the electoral college comes with the bitter anti-republican pill.
Although you win the election in November,
You can get rid of the victory in December.
The votes that are collected by the electoral college are not really votes,
but individual members of political parties,
which carry out the real vote by the president in December.
No citizen has voted to these elect to vote in his name,
and many of them are free to vote for anyone who wants to.
Your choice in December is the real choice.
The electoral college was designed to overwrite the will of the people,
or of its own electoral process,
at any time that a small number of people unknown from the party and who have not been chosen
They do not like the result they have taken.
If you are in favor of the electoral college,
you must accept it, by its own rules,
you can take away the victory
under the guise of wanting to protect yourself.
It has never happened in American history, nor should it ever.
But it is crazy to leave for future elections
a system that does not benefit the citizens
and it does not protect any state.
It's time to get rid of the polling station and have a real discussion about
As a government and a modern election must be carried out.